[Musique]
savamment sa chance il va écouter le
single de booba soir mais bien sûr à
minuit pile je les couche sur toutes les
pages tout le monde m'a dit qu'ils
avaient parce qu'en fait c'est la maison
de disques qui m'a dit il tu as fait un
cadeau de ouf dedans c'est pas ce
conseil mais mon variés aucune idée de
ce que c'est lent mais il paraît que
voilà chez ea mali vraiment une parie
que si je veux être comme un ouf ce soir
après la classe en tout cas franchement
là je viens de voir un petit dossier en
coulisses je peux commencer par ça si
vous voulez sa visite anecdote c'est un
dossier sur vous et cyril ans paraît que
cette vidéo alors je tout raconté aux
téléspectateurs amateurs savez il ya un
instant recevez théo m chipolatas donc
cyril part du studio d'à prendre ou à
laisser pour rejoindre le studio touche
mon constat et puis il voit un beau
postérieur d'auto oui de dos et il dit
il dit mais mais mais mais tu as un très
beau qu isabelle mais en fait c'était
théo de la fabrique
j'étais sur sa lette isabelle jours il a
toujours le don me mettre en avant
c'est lundi que je vois tout et je
balance tout c'est moche elle a dit que
vous l'attendez tous les jeudis et là je
crois que tu es encore du lot il ya des
très très grosses histoires drôles
indique ce soir surtout avec rooney il
faudra commencer la retard mais ça
suffit
auchel rené sera là toute la semaine du
oui ça nous a coûté cher mondiale
ouais la petite question qui est votre
chroniqueuse préféré dans l'équipe de
touche pas à mon pote sa barbe c'est on
ne sait pas si la belle au bois et les
abdos toutes les nanas ici sont toutes
superbes merveille mais vous avez bien
petit pour voila voila c'est vrai que
tout se passe bien
[Rires]
pour mettre d'accord mais tu es de la
cornemuse
j'adore la cornemuse et j'adore le jeu
le droit soyaux et dans cette emmission
une séquence un dossier à mon avis c'est
sa femme qui va rappeler juste après
pour cheikh magnéto c'était non
identifiés je reste 2003 numéro
identifiés auxquels s'est pas identifié
merci un peu très beau témoignage qui
n'a pas peur de prendre des risques
c'est vrai que sa chroniqueuse préféré
abonnés c'est isabelle isabelle tout se
passe bien avec elle l'ambiance est au
beau fixe du feeling esquif grave
à tel point que même isabelle cette
semaine à la demande et après vous elle
était inquiète de ne pas vouloir donner
sauf quand on fait trop de mérite pas la
fonction de d'isabelle quelques rendez
vous êtes un homme à femmes n'ont pas du
tout pas du haut que si vous allez au
revoir et la nouvelle target cyril elle
s'appelle evelyne thomas lé terrorisme
non j'ai vaincu les dossiers pourquoi il
n'est pas là il n'est pas la rose et
rené drouin est là
une ligue des champions de marseille mon
run il pas là il va me manquer parce que
j'en peux plus le tocard l'hiver plus
hippie de la bouche je l'enverrai un
télégramme après l'émission et thomas
est entrain d'établissement pour elle
mais c'est rien
[Applaudissements]
mais quelle tarp est magnifique
bof ce qu'elle est belle une rentrée
très chargée ma chérie pour mandater au
putting
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hop hop hop à papeete mais je m'en bats
les couilles je crois qu'elle vient
thomas il veut vraiment un canot génial
c'est qu'on voit son ami noël et des
mandats elle adore ses d'amitié
amoureuse c'est l'amitié c'est à dire la
tv oui on a d'autres choses il ya une
autre histoire d'amour qui est né dans
touche pas à mon poste
attendez je crois savoir est-ce que
c'est avec une nouvelle qu'on dit que ça
tester la foi quand nikos qui était
l'invité que voilà c'est un mec une
nouvelle chroniqueuse une arrivée comme
philippe lellouche une année des stars
virginie hocq
non j'ai vu oui il ya quelqu'un qui a
kiffé sur virgin est haute mais c'est
allé très très loin très loin c'est
quelqu'un qui a quitté alors je vais
vous dire j'ai un toit s'installe dit
non ça n'est pas dans michel ça n'est
pas qu'anissa n'est pas gilles ça n'est
pas mise à ça n'est pas bonne et c'est
beau je vois que mon nom c'était non
en comptant sur magnéto ou lola alors il
faut pas montrer ce que vous avez pas ce
que vous avez non en fait je suis payé
pour ça quand même
d'abord je je bégayais donc quand je
vais gagner
j'adore virginia et jamais aux novices à
paris mais j'aime autant ri avec un
appel inviter à vous dire virginie fait
transpirer rémy non si gvt alors voir ça
dans un instant c'est toujours dit de
mettre plus de klimesova guèye bâ on va
voir ça donne à ce qu il va rester avec
nous bien entendu et puis bien sûr on
aura tous les sujets du jour dont la
puissance 4 ce soir et on aura la
responsable de communication de lier à
chu de marseille fabrice michaud wallon
qui nous parlera du professeur raoult a
tout de suite une petite beauté c'est un
ami nous a montré cette amitié entre
isabelle morini bosc et raymond rhône et
d'ailleurs mais bon c'est un autre
dossier puisque les m'ont carrément
venez vous avez vraiment des prénoms
hyper actuelle j'adore
cent cinquante ans avec ce prénom très
actuelle que raymond donc à essayer de
pécho une chroniqueuse star de l'équipe
cyril l'a dit avant la pub je peux vous
dire qu'on assiste à une grande histoire
d'amour
en tout cas vraiment la nouvelle
chroniqueuse du fait de l'effet j'ai
juste un truc à dire aux téléspectateurs
à envoyer des images virgin glock est
allé voir le directeur des programmes
producteur je veux cabinet ski rémy
s'est il est très sympa et très sympa le
fallait pas qu'ils savaient pas qu'ils
lui dit je suis chauffeur livreur le
matin le soir je suis en rigolant 6 6 2
6 2 sa gueule non non non mais en tout
cas s'est renseigné sur monde sait pas
c'est que les femmes qui seront chers
amis c'est une amie c'est bien on rigole
jeudi
[Musique]
fils de conspirer on été transmis
là il faut être géré mon histoire qui
soit pour lui c'est bien enfin les
thèmes à 15 heures je veux qu'on achète
un 3 étoiles est cette wii 2 mois 50 une
carte que je te prête à vous les
immeubles vos disques page était dit oui
c'est spécial contrat j'ai pas confiance
en et j'ai dit oui balle et j'ai pas
confiance en moi
mais alors je voudrais qu'on ouvre tu
vois face à la mer à moment donné qu'on
ouvre toi tu veux aller à bagré tu vas
là berck marque l'âge mais dis donc
quand même nom exotique à peu à peu
exotique l'accord la corse en camping
car tu as vu le prix du bateau j'ai pas
dit ça
vous me faites pas c'est pourquoi mon
choix demain
merci tu es là nos mains c'est bon
un petit dr
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas bien ça chat alors elle est
très jolie virginie o bailon très jolie
est la grèce je vous dis j'ai jamais
autant ri avec tellement kevin mois il
encore des très beaux lots dans la mort
j'ai maintenant au nom de leur béguin
ce soir je dis rien mais je connais
raymond depuis des années mais jamais je
ne les vues dans cet état-là sentirait
qui transpirait tôt qu'est ce qui se
cache ma chérie je viens en tout cas sur
le plateau mais je parle pas d'habitude
aux invités j'aime beaucoup la wii c'est
la gmv bravo parce que vous avez
ressorti le costume de la soupe aux
choux la dic a également surveiller une
personne dont on parle pas assez je
trouve dans cette chronique c'est kylie
qu'elle était nommée l'irak est libre et
novatrice cette année la brune askan wi
elle est très très irritable on ne peut
pas s'approcher de qualif on ne peut pas
lui parler là je m'adresse à tous les
chroniqueurs qui sont des amis de ne
provoquait pas kelly elle peut monter
cette année c'est kelly versus les
chroniqueurs
[Musique]
écrit la députée fada
cette hystérique ta gueule toi commencer
ce [ __ ] con ciment mais j'en ai déjà
plein début donc déjà que tu ruine les
chefs des femmes tu ferais bien de
respecter le travail des gens comme les
yeux
c'était vraiment bien ce même vous
montez au tour de louis hébert richard
recouvert d'hématomes airscarf sur cette
mère de la starlette avis hein mais
chaque bombardement bah ouais j'ai des
combats
mais continuez comme ça mais si c'est
reporté sur maps et on n'a pas en appel
n'a pas cédé c'est pas rien et
franchement je suis très surpris par
cette jeune femme et yannick tant il
paraît qu'il est sympa que je connais
sur moi j'ai eu une seule fois si
j'échoue otis a vécu un jour et j'ai une
peau au téléphone et très sympathique
yannick noah n'ont pas dit qu'ils
avaient leur combat sera de retour lundi
d'ailleurs ne pas aller et pour finir je
pouvais pas repartir sans parler de vous
suivre partout on va m'accuser
d'impartialité il indiqué est partial
alors de parsemer temps partiel we hope
et d'impartialité l'indiqué partial bon
bref sinon on avait accusé de partialité
de partialité
mais je suis impartiale s'est concentré
sur cyril je parle de moi à la troisième
personne indique évidemment et cyrine
l'indiquent n'a pas compris quelque
chose facile mais quand vous êtes à
l'antenne qui prend possession de vous à
quoi y'a quelqu'un qui rend dans votre
corps c'est pas possible d'entendre des
personnes
la pression interne à quelques-uns parce
que quand on regarde le bateau qui va
suivre vous allez voir en fonction des
traités des réactions de cyril à mon
avis il est sur plusieurs cyril en fait
c'est un peu notre nouveau louis de
funès échos
alors oui géraldine jamais pardon mais
mes petits camarades sont tous choqués
mais en fait ils découvrent aujourd'hui
l'obscénité du consumérisme des gens des
stars comme ça les tentes il en est
conscient
[Musique]
oui mais c'est parce qu'ils font là font
l'apologie du consumérisme
voilà c'est l'éclectisme est justement
moi je ne compare pas soumise à des
trucs que je déteste chez des trucs que
j'aime
[Musique]
et tous nés des dévoués spectacle
message en disant bas la quinzaine dans
l'air du temps de parler des soignants
dont on va parler des moyens mais cela
dit il ya quand même deux personnes que
moi j'aime beaucoup ce sont les moyens
pour achever sa colère c'est pour des
tombes il avait il adhère ou pas chez
moi oui beaucoup
elle se regal voila s-300 a pas de
rigoler au début du magnéto merci en
tout cas sa seule base l'excellent
dragon